der kanzler meldet sich zu wort richtet
seine rede an die ganze nation alle
deutschen in diesen so dramatischen
kriegszeiten in der ukraine und am
vorabend ja einer sieges parade so ist
sie gelabelt von vladimir putin
russlands präsidenten und krieg sagen
dass also die rede an die nation von
kanzler scholz wir werden sie ihn gleich
in voller länge zeigen und schauen sie
hier aber schon mal in die wichtigsten
sätze des kanzlers rein
aus vielen äußerungen die ich dieser
tage höhere spricht ernste sorge sorge
auch dafür dass sich der krieg aus weit
dass der frieden auch bei uns in gefahr
geraten könnte
es wäre falsch das einfach abzutun
solche sorgen müssen ausgesprochen
werden können
gleichzeitig gilt
angst darf uns nicht leben vier klare
grundsätze folgen daraus für die politik
erstens keine deutschen alleingänge
was immer wir tun stimmen wir auf das
engste mit unseren bündnispartnern ab in
europa und jenseits des atlantiks
zweitens bei allem was wir tun achten
wir darauf unsere eigene
verteidigungsfähigkeit zu erhalten und
wir haben entschieden die bundeswehr
deutlich besser auszustatten damit sie
uns auch in zukunft verteidigen kann
drittens
unternehmen nichts was uns und unseren
partnern mehr schadet als russland und
viertens wir werden keine entscheidungen
treffen die die nato kriegspartei werden
lässt dabei bleibt es
dass es keinen weltkrieg mehr geben soll
erst recht keinen zwischen
nuklearmächten auch das ist eine lehre
des achten
dass also die wichtigsten worte des
bundeskanzlers heute aus seiner rede an
die nation die wir ihn gleich auch in
voller länge zeigen werden wir reden
über diesen kurzen ausschnitt schon mit
unserem bild parlamentschef mit ralf
schuler hier im studio bei bild live am
abend größe die greift die wichtigste
botschaft des kanzlers offenbar das ist
nicht unser krieg wir unterstützen zwar
aber wir werden nichts tun was uns zur
kriegspartei macht olaf scholz wollte
vor allem die lange strecke der chaos
kommunikation seiner partei jetzt
aufheben und versuchen eine klare ansage
zu machen viele haben an dingen
gerüttelt und gezogen und dann gesagt du
musst das besser erklären was du machst
nicht erst waffenlieferung ablehnen dann
wird doch zustimmen und das hat er heute
versucht an diesem historischen tag der
kapitulation und befreiung 1945 und hat
versucht diese vier grundsätze klar zu
machen also wir werden keine alleingänge
starten wir werden im bündnis bleiben
mit unseren partnern wir werden unsere
eigene verteidigungsbereitschaft stärken
das ist eine ankündigung im augenblick
liefern wir das letzte was wir haben
gerade an die ukraine und wir werden
nicht kriegspartei werden das waren die
essentials bisher und die hat er jetzt
noch mal bekräftigt ein sehr gemessenem
ernsthaften ton
vielleicht beeindruckt dass die menschen
ja um zeigt der kanzler weiß wo er hin
will im augenblick hatte man im bilden
nicht den eindruck dass er durch seinen
zögerlichen zaudernden kurs dalia
verunsicherten eindruck heute nachdem
wir diesen kurzer ausschnitt aus der
rede schon gesehen habe dieser sauder
kanzler dieser zöger kanzler so wie er
in den vergangenen wochen wahrgenommen
wurde in diesem krieg wird er das diesen
ruf damit los mit dieser tv-ansprache
heute abend ja ich glaube er wird ihnen
deshalb nicht ganz los weil er einfach
seinem naturell entspricht dieser ruf
und jetzt klare ansagen zu machen
bedeutet ja nicht dass bei der nächsten
kabinettssitzung jetzt auch klare
beschlüsse gefasst werden also innerhalb
der koalition muss man weiter ringen ist
noch immer nicht ganz klar wofür 100
milliarden für zusätzliche rüstung
ausgegeben werden sollen also da sind
noch sehr viele details offen und dann
verästelt sich es auch sehr schnell
wieder das waren ja vor allem wenn man
es sich genau anhört sehr allgemeine
sachen das alles dafür tun dass die nato
nicht kriegspartei wird am ende hängt es
nicht an der nato am ende hängt ist vom
aggressor putin ab ob der glaubt die in
jetzt sei es aber genug und die nato sei
jetzt dein feind dann haben wir das
problem also es gibt da sehr viele
unwägbarkeiten aber klar ist dass scholz
versuchen wollte sicherheit
auszustrahlen und führungsstärke hat ja
mal gesagt wer führung bestellt der
bekommt sie bisher hat er da nur wenig
geliefert jetzt wollte er zumindest
einen versuch machen bestellt man sich
vor in der ukraine wird man diese rede
auch mit großem interesse verfolgt haben
da kam aus berlin kamen aus deutschland
nicht immer das was man sich in der
ukraine gewünscht hat auch innerhalb
europas in der ganzen welt scharfe
kritik an den deutschen auch am
bundeskanzler jetzt wartet man auf diese
worte wartet auf ein starkes signal auch
des kanzlers in dieser tv ansprache und
wird enttäuscht ich glaube aus
ukrainischer sicht
wird man nicht allzu viel daraus
entnehmen können es war eher eine rede
an die deutschen und nicht zu sehr an
die ukraine natürlich wird deutschland
seiner verantwortung gerecht werden und
es wird auch weiter seinen kurs fahren
aber was das konkret bedeutet das wird
man einfach sehen müssen und die mittel
sind am ende auch begrenzt deutschland
kann vor allem geld ausgeben davon haben
wir noch genug aber die baustellen
werden schon mehr die
entwicklungsministerin hat von einer
hungersnot weltweit gewarnt wie wir sie
nach dem krieg nicht mehr gesehen haben
also da gibt es sehr viele baustellen
wir werden sehen ob dem wirklich auf
allen ebenen gewachsen sind